the greens are coming for you rhaenera  and for your children  you cannot bend the knee to the high  Towers they stole your Birthright  man standing around the painted table  urges her to plunge the realm into war  they Siege to the red keeper  send us  I swear towards the queen  your cause owns a power that has not  been seen since the days of old valyria  [Music]  for free you can now listen to the  entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which  house of the Dragon is based and which  covers the entire Targaryen history  including current and future events of  House of the Dragon for free with a  notable trial using our Link in the  description  foreign